Elizabeth joins us in Austin Texas
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
Elizabeth hi Mario better than I deserve
what's up so I have a question more in
regards to my parents I'm 25 years old I
have six siblings total and our parents
are going through a lot of financial
hardships they lost their house two
years ago and they've been technically
homeless since then currently my mom is
saying on my sister is callous and my
dad is saying on my couch with my other
sister and it's you know really it's
overwhelming for all of us and my
personally my dad just keeps on making
poor decisions financial decisions like
this yesterday yesterday he bought a
brand new not brand new it's our used
car that's like $30,000 of an ante our
by 23% and he's homeless living on our
couch and we're about to I mean
personally making the decisions you kind
of cut ties but it's really hard because
there are parents the religious want
your advice I'll give you like we're
trying to get ahead of our you know our
own life to be financially successful
and just feel like our parents are kind
of holding us back and we're just trying
to go the right way about it I'm sorry
that's so hard you're 25 I can't get my
head around I can't get my head around
I'm I mean I've got a 27 year old son I
can't get my head around I lost my house
two years ago you said I've told my
daughter's couch for two years and the
only thing I can come up with to do is
go buy a $30,000 car at 22 percent
interest I can't get my head around that
does he work yes he does he works at
home evil how many hours you work 40
hours a week 30 minutes minimum pay he
was his own actual own business owner
and
fielded that went to shambles he lost
once he lost that was lost everything so
he went sailing from staying on our
grandmother's couch to just coming up to
us kids and the hard thing is if we're
trying to help but you know the
mentality that they have or not my mom
but more so my father is you know like I
paid for you guys coming up so now if
y'all starting to take care of wings and
we're not really in the position like
we're all like I said trying to get
ahead of ourselves and we're on position
to do that and it's very like really
hard it's this is not gonna end well you
know that right yeah I'm so sorry
because here's the thing someone who
does not respect boundaries like your
dad when you put up boundaries which is
what you're getting ready to do he's not
gonna react well of that he feels like
he is entitled to anything you own and
that's not accurate he shouldn't feel
that way and so when you tell him he's
not entitled to anything you own just
because he sired you he's not going to
react well of that are you prepared for
that group six siblings I think we're
all trying to make that new such a
realizing that were not I'm not saying
you should cut ties with him but I think
you should quit supporting him and
because he's not making good decisions
and I don't know if he is he mentally
ill I wouldn't I think so
he might I mean I think that ever since
everything is kind of gone downhill he's
you know taking these a lot worse and
our mother's mentally ill too so mm-hmm
okay well I I think what are you by
chance are associated with a good church
you personally I am yeah good I think
you need to go see some Pastoral Council
on this and and that is
that that is strong and that is not weak
but also is kind okay and so it probably
is going to end up sounding something
like this I I don't want you to cut ties
with him I just want you to kick him out
okay that's different now he may choose
to cut ties with you because he may be
angry when you don't go along with his
plan for taking your money okay he may
choose that but you don't have to choose
that that's up to him that do so it
would sound something like this that the
decisions you're making with the money
that you have coming in with where
you're choosing to work and how you're
choosing to earn living and the purchase
of this car they don't make sense to me
I brought you in here and gave you a
place to stay not for the rest of your
life but because you were on hard times
and help you turn it around instead
you've made things worse while you were
here and so what you've got to do is
we're going to set a timeline by which
you can stay here for another month but
it is that you are going to be on a
budget you're gonna sell that car and
you're gonna start making plans and
working all the hours you can work to
get a deposit together to go rinse you
your own place a grown man like you
should have the dignity of standing on
his own and that's how you taught us and
that's how you're gonna have to do dad
and I love you and I'll support you and
I'll be your biggest cheerleader but you
can't sleep on my couch after that after
one month from today or two months I
don't care you don't kick him out this
Friday you know but but this is going
the problem as this seems to be going on
until he's 90 and you're 40 and that's
gotta stop here has to be an end to it
so if it's one month or two months I
don't care give him a little room to
give him an up ramp to get on you know
to get back off the ground he's gotta
have enough runway to get off the ground
right it's an it's an entrance ramp on
his new interstate of life and so we'll
give him a ramp but but that's what I
mean I don't think it's Friday it's very
gentle and very calm and if he reacts
poorly and starts
having a fit and is raging does he do
that he does do that yes yeah he will
definitely play a good big field trip
get up yeah so here's the thing that if
you're gonna mistreat me you can't stay
here at all
you can only stay here if you can have
manners and you can only stay here long
enough to get back up on your own feet
and I'm designating that to be X amount
of time and this is not because I don't
love you it's because I do love you and
you seem to be stuck and I want to see
you go be the man that I used to know
the dad that I grew up with who was a
provider and no dad I do not owe you the
rest of your life staying on my couch I
don't I'm not in debt to you that I love
you but I'm not in debt to you that was
your job as dad to raise us well you
didn't raise us so that we could turn
around and take you know somehow we're
required to take care of you and your
misbehavior this is gonna be painful you
need your brothers and sisters around
you you need a good pastor around you to
walk you through this very difficult to
do at 25 years old you can do it though